[Music]
hi everyone it's joanna here don't we
all just wish that our body is able to
burn fat more efficiently all day long
well i know i do when it comes to
burning fat it is highly associated with
our body's metabolism yup your fat
burning machine is your body's
metabolism therefore it is safe to say
that if we can keep our metabolism
healthy and active then we would be able
to turn on our fat burn mood throughout
the day which can also help with weight
loss so in this video i'd like to share
with you some of the top workouts and
food choices that can boost your
metabolism and encourage your body to
continue burning fat all day long
so before we get into the food and
workouts let's first understand your
body's metabolic rate which is also
referred to as the body's total daily
energy expenditure
tdee is basically the number of calories
one burns in a day tdee is different for
everybody and is influenced by four main
components
basal metabolic rate bmr
exercise activity thermogenesis eat
non-exercise activity thermogenesis
needs and thermic effect of feeding tef
basal metabolic rate or often known as
bmr constitutes 60 to 70 percent of our
tdee
bmr is the minimum number of calories
that your body needs to function at rest
next is the exercise activity
thermogenesis which constitute about 5
to 10 of our tdee it refers to planned
structured and repetitive physical
activities such as hitting the gym or
going for a jog on the other hand
non-exercise activity thermogenesis
refers to the energy we burn through
non-sports activities such as doing
house chores cooking and even small
movements like fidgeting or playing a
musical instrument
neat makes up about 10 to 20 percent of
our tdee
and the final component is the thermic
effect of feeding which makes up about
10 of our tdee
this refers to the amount of energy we
use to eat digest and metabolize our
food so with this information we know
that in order to promote more fat burn
throughout the day we should be looking
at improving the biggest contributor to
our tdee which is our bmr here are the
top 3 workout modes to improve your bmr
strength training is a mode of training
that helps you increase your muscular
strength and build lean muscle mass
strength training is important because
your bmr is largely determined by your
total lean muscle mass so muscle mass
burns more calories than fat for every
pound of lean muscle mass your body
burns an additional 14 calories a day
whereas a pound of fat only burns 2 to 3
calories hence the more lean muscle you
have on your body the higher your bmr
will be which increases your body's fat
burning ability
examples of strength training includes
exercises with gym machines or free
weights such as dumbbells barbells
kettlebells or equipment such as a
resistance band or even body weight
exercises such as push-ups and pull-ups
so those who add strength training two
to three times a week burns
significantly more fat than those who
only perform cardio exercises
high intensity interval training or more
commonly known as hit involves quick
intense burst of activity some common
exercises used in a heat session are
burpees squat jumps and sprinting
the whole goal is to push your body into
an anaerobic state and for you to empty
your tank this will not only help you
burn tons of calories in a short period
of time however
it will also help keep your metabolism
elevated even after your workout is over
through a process called excess post
exercise oxygen consumption
epoc or more commonly known as the after
burn effect
this refers to all of the oxygen and
energy in the form of calories that your
body takes in and uses after exercise to
help repair your muscles and recover the
afterburn effect can last up to 36 hours
therefore heat has become a famous
training mode as it is known to help
fire up your metabolism throughout the
entire day
[Music]
compound exercises are multi-joint
movements that are designed to target
multiple muscle groups at one time
examples of compound movements include
squat to shoulder press lunges push-ups
and plank roll
most compound exercises will not only
challenge your muscular fitness but it
will also get your heart rate up and
improve your cardio fitness while
burning lots of calories to simplify how
doing compound exercises could boost
your metabolism let us look at our
muscles as a factory the more muscles we
work at one time the more energy is
needed to power the factory thus
increasing our body's metabolism so most
of my workout videos are based on
compound movements do check them out on
my youtube channel and they are perfect
especially for those of you who have
very limited time right now that you
know the right type of workouts to start
including into your fitness routine let
us not neglect the most important aspect
to weight loss which is our food here
are my top 5 functional foods that are
known to help you boost your metabolism
[Music]
as mentioned previously our metabolism
is linked to our muscle mass therefore
it is important to always fill our
muscles with the protein it needs the
guideline to follow is that 20 to 30
percent of your total daily calories
should come from protein
this can be easily met by including a
serving of protein such as lean meat
fish
nuts legumes or yogurt at every meal and
snack this in turn will ensure that our
muscles continue to efficiently function
as a powerhouse to burn fat as fuel
throughout the day
on top of that did you know that protein
causes the largest rice in thermic
effect of feeding
in comparison to carbs or fats
this is because protein takes longer for
the body to break down which means that
it needs more calories to digest absorb
and process the nutrients in your meals
it can increase your metabolic rate by
fifteen to thirty percent compared to
five to ten percent for cups and only
zero to three percent for fats
therefore consuming plenty of protein
can make you burn an extra 150 to 200
calories in a day plus you will feel
full and prevent overeating
studies have shown that caffeine in
coffee can boost metabolism by three to
eleven percent
this is why if you were to take a look
at fat burners most of them have
caffeine as the number one ingredient
now that doesn't mean that you should
just be sipping on coffee all day long
and be a caffeine addict and expect to
lose weight you still need to put the
effort in drinking a cup of black coffee
before a workout can improve your
workout performance speed up your
metabolism hence help you burn fat more
efficiently and that's something i
personally practice one cup of coffee
right before my training session
this next food is probably one of your
favorite desserts dark chocolate yup
dark chocolate is definitely one of the
yummiest snacks out there that can help
you boost your metabolism the
monounsaturated fats present in dark
chocolate is not only known to boost
your metabolism but also improve your
gut flora thus improving digestion in
addition dark chocolate also contains an
amino acid called tryptophan that your
brain uses to produce the
neurotransmitter serotonin which can
increase feelings of overall happiness
now burn fat and feeling happy at the
same time this is my go-to snack so the
next time you crave for dessert opt for
a small amount of dark chocolate
capsaicin found in chili peppers are
known to help boost metabolism by
slightly increasing the rate at which
your body burns calories
studies have shown that they may help
your body burn around 50 extra calories
per day besides that according to a
review of studies in nearly 200 people
consuming at least 2 milligrams of
capsaicin directly before each meal
appears to reduce calorie consumption
especially from carbs so
spice up your meals and turn up the fat
burn mode
we all know the importance of water but
did you know that your body needs water
to process calories hence if you're even
slightly dehydrated your metabolism may
slow down experts suggest that drinking
8 to 10 glasses of water per day would
increase your daily energy demand by at
least 95 calories so
keep yourself hydrated throughout the
day some really simple tricks to drink
more water daily is to drink a glass
once you're up in the morning and drink
a glass of water before every meal or
consume a healthy vegetable soup before
your meal and also snack on fresh fruits
and vegetables which naturally contain
water
water helps to fill you up which means
those who drank more water will tend to
eat less food
now what you want to avoid are sugary
drinks and alcohol as they contain empty
calories but can add up over time and
cause weight gain although almost all
foods will increase your metabolism
these are some top foods that can give
you a good kick to your metabolic rate
and help you burn more calories provided
that you add sufficient amount of
physical activity with it even though we
often link metabolism with weight loss
metabolism is responsible for so much
more such as having energy mental
clarity and it is essentially the
foundation of everything we do hence
remember that a healthy metabolism is
the first step in helping your body in
burning fat more efficiently throughout
the day and this is fundamentally
achieved by pairing an active lifestyle
with a well-balanced diet so i hope you
enjoyed this video i hope that you have
learned some tips and tricks to start
implementing into your fitness routine
and if you like this video do give this
video a thumbs up and don't forget to
hit the subscribe button if you haven't
yet done it go on to my youtube channel
and check out a lot more workout videos
and nutrition tips fitness tips as well
as healthy recipes and i will see you in
my next video
all the best